[Music]
on this friday night
pregnancy and protection from covet 19.
the new recommendations from others to
be and the risks
we're reading the information with a
slightly different lens
destruction in downtown nashville we do
believe that the explosion was an
intentional act
the investigation into an enormous blast
a coveted christmas ceremonies that
changed
and traditions that are untouchable i
feel blessed
is one of the best days
global national with donna friesen
recording tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us on this christmas day
there are now two coveted 19 vaccines
that have been approved by health canada
but tonight there are questions
about whether women who are pregnant or
trying should get vaccinated
the national committee that is advising
the government on immunization has
provided some guidance on this issue
abigail beeman is looking into what
other countries are doing
new this week canada's national advisory
committee on immunization recommends it
would be prudent to delay pregnancy by
at least
28 days after the completion of a tudo
series of vaccines
based on really
expert opinion and trying to be as
safe as possible but really is not based
on any data
earlier this month nasi released other
recommendations in general pregnant
women shouldn't get the vaccine due to a
lack of clinical evidence
but for those at a higher risk nasi says
the vaccine
may be offered i think it's always going
to be an individual decision dr debra
money is one of the authors of a
statement from the society of
obstetricians and gynecologists of
canada taking a similar view
for those at high risk of infection and
or morbidity the documented risk of not
getting the vaccine
outweighs the theorized and undescribed
risk of being vaccinated during
pregnancy
there is evidence pregnant women can get
more seriously sick with covet 19
but as for those with a low risk the
sogc
doesn't offer a hard no unlike nasty
we would obviously much prefer that
there was actually
evidence of safety and efficacy in
pregnancy but we're not likely to get
that information for a very long time
and in the meantime to completely
exclude pregnant women from
being able to access the vaccine felt
unhelpful the sogc advice is in line
with the united
states while the united kingdom takes a
harder no stance in general
we have have no evidence of harm
and i think they're just trying to be
extra careful because pregnant women
have been excluded from from trials that
have been done to date and that's a bit
of a touchy issue
dr eliana castillo believes pregnant
women should be part of vaccine trials
she says the lack of data contributes to
fear a fear
that the public takes on
and then we wonder why patients are
hesitant
sometimes dr castillo sees many patients
worried about whether to get vaccinated
and points out so many vulnerable health
care workers in canada are of
child-bearing age
with conflicting information out there
all experts stress talking to your own
health care provider to help make the
right choice
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the vaccine rollout is one of many
topics prime minister justin trudeau
discusses with our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson
in a special year-end interview you can
watch the in-depth conversation tonight
on global it'll also air sunday
on the west block the streets were
eerily quiet across the united kingdom
today as families celebrated christmas
apart
under strict measures to prevent a surge
of covet 19.
today the queen acknowledged the
incredible sacrifices
in her annual christmas day speech
crystal gomezing reports
it's not exactly a quick trip down candy
cane lane
trucks are moving through the euro
tunnel and at the port of dover
but it's slow going
more british military members have been
pressed into service to speed up covet
19 testing of drivers
the backlog of transport trucks in
england another unexpected twist in a
year
knotted up like a string of christmas
lights every year
we herald the coming of christmas by
turning on the lights
and light does more than create a
festive mood
light brings hope in her annual
christmas speech the queen
spoke of her faith and how humanity has
illuminated
many dark days from those who have
inspired us
to those providing care for many this
time of year will be tinged with sadness
some mourning the loss of those dear to
them
and others missing friends and family
members
distance for safety when all they'd
really want for christmas is a simple
hug
or a squeeze of the hand if you are
among them
you are not alone words from a queen but
also
a grandmother and mother separated from
her family
an additional six million people in
england will be moving
to a lockdown on boxing day along with
mainland scotland
and northern ireland after a last minute
christmas eve brexit deal prime minister
boris johnson
is back to trying to sue the nation
ravaged by the virus
i still think that feeling of hope is
all around us this christmas because
there really is a star in the sky and it
is glowing brighter
and brighter he says the star is the
vaccine
and as more people around the world are
inoculated
2021 looks to be a better year
crystal commansing global news london
japan is reporting five cases of the new
variant of the virus and france is
reporting one
this highly infectious version of kova
19 was first detected in britain
there's also a mutated strain in south
africa and canada is keeping an eye on
all of it
health canada says the government is
closely monitoring the genetic variants
in the uk
south africa and elsewhere all travelers
trying to enter canada from those
countries
will be subject to secondary screening
and enhanced measures
including increased scrutiny of
quarantine plans
two breaking news from nashville where
the fbi is investigating an explosion
that shook the city
tonight a state of civil emergency and a
curfew are in effect
as chris pallone reports investigators
believe this bombing
was no accident the damage in downtown
nashville shocking i'd say back two
blocks we've had some type of large
explosion
along 2nd avenue north shattered glass
smashed bricks and burned out cars
that heavy structural damage to multiple
buildings
it happened around 6 30 christmas
morning in front of an iconic fixture in
the nashville skyline the a-t-t
building police called to the area for
reports of shots fired
shortly before the blast as also
responded they encountered
an rv that had a recording
saying that a potential bomb would
detonate within 15 minutes
officers upon hearing that decided to
evacuate the building
moments later the rv exploded we do not
know
whether anyone was in the rv when it
exploded
investigators are calling it an
intentional act
several buildings have been damaged
three people were taken to the hospital
police say none of the injuries is
life-threatening now the two biggest
unanswered questions
who did it and why putting everything we
have
into finding who was responsible for
what's happened here today
president trump and acting attorney
general jeff rosen have been briefed on
the investigation
the fbi has taken it over chris pallone
nbc news
a world of difference coming up how the
pandemic has changed holiday traditions
around the world
plus the bargain price for the king of
pop's palace
2020 has been a year like no other in
recent memory and this christmas is no
exception
whether for those simply enjoying the
holidays or the many christians
celebrating the birth of jesus
pandemic precautions had to be observed
across festivities around the world
shawn o'shea reports on how they managed
for the world's two and a half billion
christians this is a day of great
celebration the birth of jesus
in bethlehem but for the masks christmas
almost looked normal
but right outside manger's square near
the church of the nativity is empty
another sign of how the coronavirus
pandemic has changed
everything this year in vatican city
this is how pilgrims would typically
mark the birth of christ
but in 2020 no one was allowed to gather
here
pope francis wishing all a merry
christmas from inside
amid a group of only about 200 faithful
socially spaced out in pews
where francis acknowledged darkness and
uncertainty seen this year
in rome a christian charity handed out
meals and gifts to the poor and homeless
i feel blessed is one of the best days
in the philippines services went ahead
too
with restrictions you will follow all
the protocols of the government
in iraq they sang carols outside of
churches
some still gathered but with fewer
family members the daughter of a church
deacon expressing hope
dina hekmat says life must go on we must
celebrate our holiday
and we are celebrating but in sydney
australia revelers had different ideas
crowds wearing santa hats jumped and
sang there was little evidence of social
distancing
in ontario about to start a
province-wide lockdown only 10 people
were allowed in the cavernous
st michael's cathedral basilica to
celebrate mass
shared on a live stream father edward
curtis admitting it's been a rough
christmas so far
and especially this year when we're not
able to gather
with the people that we love
but in paris a coral concert at notre
dame cathedral
closed after a fire destroyed its spire
and roof 18 months ago
musicians wearing boiler suits and hard
hats playing here for the first time
since the inferno
a celebration giving hope that better
times are ahead
shawn o'shea global news toronto michael
jackson's
neverland ranch has finally been sold
billionaire
ron berkel once an associate of jackson
bought it for 22 million
u.s the pop star's retreat has been on
and off the market
at one time the asking price was a
hundred million
the property has been at the center of
many child abuse allegations
in 2005 jackson stood trial accused of
molesting a boy at neverland
the singer denied the charges and was
found not guilty
he never returned to the ranch
afterwards he died in 2009
up next behind the scenes global
national at home work
and out in the field
[Music]
and that is global national for this
christmas day i hope you all have a
happy
safe and healthy holiday we appreciate
you making time for us
every night like many of you a lot of
our colleagues have been working from
home this year
sometimes their office mates are very
young or have four legs
so here's our tribute to the teams
behind global national the new reality
and our election
specials thank you for watching merry
christmas and i'll see you again in 2021
good night
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you really need a haircut oh my goodness
oh my goodness a little too
coming out
see you later guys
you